we're back for part two of our worth of
Taiwan series today we're doing su
Taiwan style
it's amazing cuz it's so hot in Taiwan
and yet they love their soup here
see them for breakfast lunch and dinner
so many great dishes to try but before
we get there
Steven where are we we are here at the
jeans I shall I'll pave salt fields all
right Inca in guy job historically one
of the earliest salt producing areas of
Taiwan ocean water comes in the Sun
evaporates it you're left of salt
speaking of salty liquids sweat no oh
we're doing soup today I'm worth it
we're gonna be trying three Taiwanese
soup set three drastically different
price points to find out which one is
most worth it at its price it's so windy
the typhoon just passed so we're heading
a little bit north of the city of Tainan
to where income we're going to die you
to have some fish soup at lien told me
you tongue thing is my last name and
cloning is smart so we're just going to
like the smart version of me twice
that'll be a extra special treat I want
very hot yes
soup is a very hot food why did I want
to see what love soup so much saltier
I'm Ducklin trait our job to know she
does work on concentration which I've
heard about I got silver mine tidy deal
zucchini and that's out slow it's only
yesterday my daughter and a gentleman a
ton says it's it was it shook it
violently maybe out some attack or tie
your legacy wait tell it quality
occurrences okay one chilly showers go
down maybe while eating far what kind of
fish is in this here memento yes a young
Tori and me a new i/o oriented I want
attention knock waviness a Tom Povich
encoder Cueva gonna take a seesaw da da
la causa Wanda Ndamukong Suh Yong Chi
Yong - ku canteen say Tong Tong somebody
chose an outdoor one son target audience
is young woman IP n just travail woman
does sits high table is right front oh
damn phone control fatigue Idaho son I
won't
you know chair turn your rhetoric over
you send a prophet now shot Rotolo time
why is the fish fried and then headed
afterwards sorry it's all cheap I want
agree I'm dying she's in a open channel
you know some electronic okay pops when
you know in your agenda
are you know telling you hold on
straight punch and stop Champa Honda
Toyota in no way home huh guys cheap
won't happen to it I noticed that
customers can come back with their bowls
and get more broth soma Guineans I see
you got rotten told you or not fountains
it's Edina
chattering yang terjadi jakotsu she
burns and she says you know my daughter
Kolkata to all my talent it's a
grammatical joining Dominion put your
tongue Thailand that jackets you sure
[Music]
yeah
what's the plate 400 is this your beer
yes yeah here Steven look at that logo
fish soup beer I'm blown away
Cheers in Mandarin is Gombe is that
right i'm bae okay that was very
unexpected Wow again Wow a thousand
times very refreshing it is give me one
word Wow
so this is the marquee piece right here
should I bite into this hmm this is like
a dish that dares you to want something
else you want vegetables boom we got it
you want tofu forget about he want pork
we got it right here you want fish boom
fry it we can do it yeah when she was
listening ingredients it was just like
the NBA all-star game and here we of the
tofu next up turbid y'all ready for this
haha now your team in China
traders as a sheet over 200 kilometer
being the PDS taco you don't go and quit
eat alright turkey rice I love how this
soup with all this stuff they were like
not you still need some turkey rice
that's right it was one thing we learned
here in Taiwan you cannot leave a
restaurant hungry they will assault you
with food in the most lovingly way
possible yeah hmm it's just jerking meat
and fat on a bowl of rice it's great if
you weren't an adventurous eater this
would seem like a scary bowl of food hmm
but it all just kind of blends into this
big soft hug I don't know it tastes nice
you get a kind taste that's exactly how
you say in manner in them really good
eat right good taste
yeah how to me
good eat good taste yeah what's bread
the kindness once I finish this meal it
will be so long until I get to eat this
again and that makes me sad I know this
whole trip is actually just it's the
worst that super was incredible in the
rainbow of soup to stew this was
somewhere in the middle and like the
stoop stupid yeah so before we get to
our next soup decided to get some treats
at the garden night market Tainan is my
favorite treats at night market it is a
peanut roll with ice cream and cilantro
what cilantro and a dessert I guess it
makes sense we put mint in desserts and
that's just Oh either green leaf think
of that cheers Cheers Wow
I like dessert cilantro so our next soup
is actually going to be hotpot how bout
that archaeologists have found pots from
2000 years ago that may have been used
to make an early iteration of hotpot
these were found in the unhu' Province
of China Wow old hotpot there hop-hop
for me everybody Thanksgiving in the Lim
family we always always always eat
hotpot
it would make sense that soup was one of
the oldest things humans ate yeah just
water doesn't stuff in there and eat it
tomorrow hotpot you go where are we
going we are going to my you noodle
sauce I'll go out to eat some beef soup
as I'm talking about beef soup get that
hot pot throw some beef in there throw
some soup in there throw some veggies in
there whatever you want what I eat
excuse me
so tuna peanut
why do you love hot pot so much fun
Lucas insha allah assalamu the country
cont no concern for have developers
intimate attention romanian government I
want cote de San Choi soo-young who
tentative uncommon and I sound like a
Tokyo right I'm the oldest I'm a j1 cook
I want a stone polite how often do you
get the deliveries wait time me pen ma
time
what so she has a long time since
outside though sweet how do we all know
Santana wake up beside you or carnosine
we saw that it arrived by taxi is it
always come by taxi away well my message
entered sidewalk sort it didn't so cool
I am i busy awful weather that's so cool
the meat takes a cab to every people
yogurt sauce honey man-eater super home
theater now just be a theater man neon
an Italian my team funnyman she's gonna
be ok if I screw tight so I persuade to
just inform amantha
I'll check y'all there's also vegetables
in the dish already what an email
suicide sit weather t wait that's a size
of the county time then await our P G
home in like a cow on the way down
yes I just don't want it for someone
who's never had hop up before how do you
eat it
touch it will not have a man that I saw
no sign yeah doc I see yonder I want any
color tends to year weather but I'm
sorry I feel good it's like Johnny D in
Tijuana Tokyo
come on puta by equine law to say quinoa
they were very nervous since I don't
want to know cuz it Wanda happy Sean and
he had a townhome money--which ever ha
ha honey hello Duncan
Taylor make well over hope out oh yeah
you also have this pork rice it's free
for all the customers location CB da
house on team de-iced one color I think
antioxidant no high pay pay one load
often JP get back
[Music]
we be in a lot of beef on this show but
this is some of the prettiest beam I've
ever seen
the color is ridiculous whole brood long
this is one of the coolest things
it's like t snow globe and it's got the
net you know hey Cheers
hmm want to start with this one let's do
it let's hold Oh cat cheers Steven one
two
Wow going in one mmm
Oh No this smell is incredible
Cheers oh that's nice bean we're just
getting to eat a really nice steak
yeah with soup and you get to eat it the
second it's done cooking
mmm I'm gonna try the same piece of meat
this time but now dip it shabu shabu
shabu that rocks hang in there yeah all
right absolutely one
- whoa three like you're baptizing the
meat the dip is awesome okay that's
doing that right there's two great ways
to enjoy beef you either cook it very
briefly or you cook it a really long
time this is the best of both worlds -
quick cook beef and also the super long
confit because the soup is a 10 to 12
hour deep in beef bone soup
but enough about beef pork break or
break mm-hmm
at first this did not make sense but
it's because the beef is so precious it
breaks up the flow so I don't just crush
my plate of beef all in one bite like I
want to well and also this bowl of rice
is bringing me more comfort than my body
pillow what I got the same one for over
10 years it's hard to sleep without it
Wow no I wash it that explains a lot
about here it's like a teddy bear we all
have that like item yeah but now mine is
in my parents attic because they stopped
sleeping with it after the age of eight
why would you give up something that's
so comfortable all right we're gonna
have the broth now we've finally reached
the soup part of the meal whoo the smell
though tears
whoo that is nice it's not so beefy
actually it's got like Rudy flavor
yeah apples or something this is the
best way to close out this meal yeah
it's nice a gentle landing it's like
when you have a delicious sauce you want
a piece of bread to mop it up top the
sauce here you just drink the sauce hot
pot that hot pot was so good okay so
we've come to Taichung for our final
soup but before we have that we're gonna
have some cold drinks that's right we're
going to 10r in one of my favorite
places in the States so lots of be
having it here in Taiwan where it's
actually from so we've got long tea and
a black tea boba confession time I'm not
the biggest fan of boba that's fine
I just eating while drinking I don't
isn't that what soup is soup is drinking
while eating it's completely different
don't get it twisted Cheers mmm that's
what I like
unsweetened nice iced tea that's all I
want instead of another soup fact we're
actually gonna have a boba fact
lower-fat boba tea was invented in the
1980s in Thai trauma Oh some genius out
here putting boba and milky together
their controversies around who actually
invented bubble milk tea there's
multiple reports of different people so
interesting we're now on our way to goo
ba me where we're going to see chef Chen
to try her beef noodle soup the iconic
dish of Taiwan we've had it a few times
off-camera so far just for our crew
meals and such and it's usually a very
inexpensive dish five or six US dollars
equivalent but today's is going to be a
little bit more deluxe it's gonna cost
around 30 US dollars which is a lot for
beef noodle soup but it's gonna be
really good
Ruba me is beef noodles in Taiwanese
dialect why do you think taiwan loves
their beef noodle soup so much it's fast
and also its luxury you have a big bowl
of noodle soup and meat I never really
see restaurants can do all three good I
want to do things the best so when I do
noodles I want to find out the best
formula to eat test with different
flours for almost six months I would say
we won the noodles to be authentic in
the middle but also the outside can
absorb a little bit the suit we use the
Japanese Wagyu beef shank and also we
have a condiment of smoked bone marrow
and on top of a we have some shabu shabu
of the beef shank to give two different
textures of the meat what is your
background in cooking like where did you
come from I learned in Paris I travelled
to stay so a little bit and then I come
back I started my French fresh run ten
years ago very fine dining it was my
dream restaurants buddies in Thai truck
is very weird
I think Taiwan people they like
something casual I want to do something
similar and now I have a bar AB noodle
shop I was just trying to do something I
like it looks like very refined but I
didn't do it on purpose I just tried to
make it good and then it becomes this
way look at this that's not soup we have
tofu skin hooked in some of the beef
stock this is the radish with lemon and
olive oil
zucchini confit and goose fat some kind
of green bean and beef mushroom
deliciousness I know there's a lot of
delicious stuff in front of us I cannot
wait for the soup right now
but I will be patient
[Music]
roll along hold on the soup that is damn
good green bean oh I did not think that
was gonna taste like that it's a smoky
porky green bean tofu skin that was
super juicy and you know Cheers
that's the best one no this is the best
no no no no I'm done zucchini confit in
goose fat every time I eat something
green I expect it to taste like a crisp
vegetable then it tastes like a fatty
animal this is awesome Wow finally the
beef Oh ready to eat some dude in the
soup right now oh thank you no this
thing I can't believe this I can't
believe this
yeah I can't believe this this is a $30
bold soup broth Cheers
[Music]
okay I didn't think a beef tastes can be
refreshing
yeah problem yeah let's do the choice
cut meat on top
Wow very flavorful beep okay jeez I
literally just ate a pastrami sandwich
in one bite
yeah and the juices of the soup just
bursting out inca have some come come
come
[Music]
there's always those are great noodles
springy chewy look at that beef Wow holy
crap I didn't think I was gonna be that
soft what yeah it's like softer than
happy it's softer than it's somewhere be
kidding me
okay let's add the bone marrow this is
like buttering already buttered bread
[Music]
Wow including all the steaks we be in
this beef best beef taste I've ever
tasted the best part I get to eat
noodles the whole time it's like usually
a steak yours eating steak pretty fun
but okay noodles the whole time yeah
I've had a lot of beef in those two
before and it's never bad it's always
satisfying and comforting but this one
is like what was born in Akron Ohio
autumn the chosen one Annie's the
magazine when I was 14 there not be a
great baffle player
LeBron James oh god damn it every time
goo ba me one of the best soup dishes
I've ever had one of the best noodle
dishes I've ever had one of the best
beef dishes I've ever had Algy we did
there before we get to our worth it
winners Andrew what was your favorite
thing that was not a soup in this
episode the craft beer at smart fish oh
I never thought I'd see a beer with a
fish soup logo what was your favorite
non-supe thick beef taxi there's nothing
even a escort beef in the taxi beef out
the taxi okay Stephen which soup was
most worth it to you I thought smart
fish soup with Anna Wintour when we ate
there I thought the beef hop ha was
gonna be my winner when we ate there but
goo ba me is my worth of winner today so
beefy just so much thought put into it
my worth it winner goes to smart fish Oh
fish soup was crazy truly one of the
most unique dishes I've ever eaten
Thank You Annie boo ba me
what Madame who's your worth a winner
what yeah yeah I've never been so this
is a win today that's it for worth it
Taiwan soup we have one more episode in
this mini series coming up next Stephen
what is it chicken
[Music]